[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and
welcome to
what's on my phone 2019. see
i've done this sort of thing roughly
once a year and it always tends to be
kind of the same as the last year but
this year i'm gonna put a little bit
more of the
other devices that i use so it's more of
a look at the ecosystem of
things that i use somewhat daily right
now and this is right at that like
perfect time of the year where
we're in the lull after the holiday
season where i can sort of settle into
one device for more than
a month at a time we're about to start
to get new phones again but
for the moment this is what i've chosen
uh to settle into so you probably notice
i have two phones in front of me i'm
gonna go through them both
i'm gonna start with my android phone
but i do carry an
android phone of choice and an iphone of
choice as you know
those phones are pixel 3 xl
and iphone 10s max black
space gray all right so this is my
probably pretty familiar looking uh
pixel
setup at this point like i've said not a
ton changing but i'll go through uh the
the icons on widgets anyway
i'll leave the wallpaper link below of
course but uh tick tick that's my to-do
list app
i don't think i'd be nearly as
productive
without actually writing things down as
when i actually write them down like if
you ask me to do something and i don't
write it down and i tell you i'm gonna
do it
i'm not gonna do it i actually have to
write it down but then i have google
keep which i see they've called
keep notes now um but it's just to keep
lists of things and
to remember what's upcoming then there's
instagram i think we all know instagram
is
and then there's google photos over here
which is the stock photos app for
the pixel then pocket casts and this is
something i've gotten more into lately
but i've started
listening to more podcasts from various
creators there's podcast networks
there's news sites and
all sorts of people do podcasts now nba
players even
so i use the pocketcast app to sort
through those
download them listen to them on flights
and car rides and things like that i use
relay pro still
for reddit uh i use a different reddit
app on the iphone but i'll get into that
later
relay pro is great that's the tesla app
i haven't had my car for at this point
almost three months and there's an
update on that coming very soon but i
still have the tesla app lonely hasn't
been opened in a while on my phone then
there's spotify
um that's just all the music i listen to
a lot of music still in the car
or whether i'm working out or whatever
i'm doing and i have actually added
an mkbhd videos playlist and i'll i've
started linking that below as well so
the video
intro music you hear in a lot of videos
you can find it on spotify and so i've
started adding them to this playlist so
shout out to spotify so the last two on
this row youtube studio app
pretty uh pretty standard stuff i think
you've all seen that before
and google maps i'd be lost without it
but i use waze which is on my next page
at the bottom i always have my text app
and the dialer i have my camera always
over there and part of the reason i've
been using the pixel
for for all this time especially over
my second favorite phone right now in
the android world which is the oneplus
6t
is the camera the oneplus is a better
performer it is significantly faster
smoother
doesn't hiccup nearly as much has way
more ram it's just more pleasurable to
use
but the camera's not as good and every
time i come back and take photos on this
pixel's camera
it reminds me why i really liked it in
the first place so that's going to be
something
really difficult for other phones to top
in the future but pixel's camera is
what's keeping me here
then i have the play store and i also
have my twitter app of choice on android
it's called flamingo
it's no longer available for additional
users
in the play store so it's kind of a
useless shout out but it's one of my
favorite twitter apps of all time but i
don't get notifications through it
i use the the official twitter app for
notifications so that's my sort of weird
twitter situation and i'll scroll over
uh there's my calendar app i forgot the
name of it but it's really good so i'll
link it below and it just lets you click
on the calendar from up top
and then there's waze this is what i use
for navigation so it'll tell you if
there's potholes on the road ahead
or if there's anything like closed roads
or construction traffic is really really
good with waze
so i recommend waze then there's yahoo
fantasy
i recently dethroned the best team in
our league but i'm
only 11 and 5 in the 16 weeks of the nba
season so i'm not
not on top yet shout out to jesse and i
think that's
uh that's mike so good job campy then i
have my fitness pal which is
an app basically used to track macros
and fitness and calories and things like
that then soundcloud my second favorite
music app
uh stuff that's not on spotify which is
very little
i can listen to on soundcloud and then
group me for all the group chat
action but of course like any other
android phone there are plenty of apps
that are not on my home screen
that are still on my phone accuweather
is just a
great weather app i think most people
know what that does aftership is pretty
good for just letting you know what
happened with your packages
whether they've arrived yet you can see
the titanium red hydrogens that i
ordered
are on the way so android auto audible
audible's good for audiobooks i've read
at least three books in the last year so
that's pretty good
breather i haven't used that in a while
but i've talked about it before lets you
rent space in your area if you live in a
city where there's a lot of breathers
in calculator calendar camera chrome
clock
coinbase remember bitcoin
good times dark sky dark sky is a really
good hyper local weather app so it's
sort of crowdsourced and wow that's a
lot of
rain or something coming awesome but
it's a hyper local weather app and it
can give you notifications about if it's
going to rain
in the next couple of minutes it'll say
hey it's going to start drizzling in 17
minutes and raining hard and 24.
i know exactly how long you have to get
out of wherever you're at so
i like dark sky google fitness i don't
use as much you may notice i wear an
apple watch
and i've developed this uh obsession
with closing my rings
it's what a lot of people with apple
watches end up doing it's telling me to
breathe right now uh headphones this is
the sony headphones app so you guys saw
that i reviewed the sony
wh-1000xm3s
pretty recently that was with minimal
experience with the app and there's a
couple cool features in the app where
you can customize what it does but
that's the app on my phone now then
there's a healthmate app which is
connected to
a digital scale that i have literally
tells me
mostly just how much i weigh but you
guys didn't know how much i weighed so
there's your uh your insight into that
hashtag gains
phillips hue there's a couple phillips
hue lights in here including
that one behind my desk that's been
there for
years now gotta love philips hue stuff
uh i also have the lifx app
because i've been experiment
experimenting with those they talk to
google home as well and that
i don't have to go through all these uh
ld is called lens distortions so you can
open up a photo in the lens distortions
app
and then there's a whole bunch of
different effects built in that you can
play with
to adjust how the photo looks adds
essentially overlays that you can adjust
opacity intensity of and filters it's
pretty cool i don't use it that much
but it is useful at what it does and i
also have lightroom mobile that i use
even less often than the actual built-in
photo editor in google photos but it is
good for certain things as well then
there's the me ross app that's
an app that i got specifically for a
smart plug
that needed to use that app to talk to
it but then it could turn on and off a
holiday tree for the past year so
it worked there's nest there's pandora i
only have two different wallpaper apps
that i use regularly one of them is
papers
and it's very similar to the other one i
use which is called
wally down here at the bottom w-a-l-l-i
i'm also gonna try to link
as many of these apps as possible down
below so the description is gonna be
really long
but ideally you can find everything
there then we're getting down to the end
i have a photo blend app
i have pocket casts i have the regular
reddit app
that's good for notifications i have
slack
i have resplash what is resplash oh it's
more
it's more wallpapers i forgot i had a
third one i don't use this one as much i
have the stockx app this one
uh can be a bit of a problem because if
you're into shoes
or street wear but for me mostly just
shoes then you can just kind of
endlessly graze through here and find
things that you want
uh highly recommended and then you get
to the bottom and there's youtube
youtube tv youtube music
youtube studio and zillow for just
perusing real estate
and that's basically it so that's that's
the apps that are on my android phone
again i don't use all these apps all the
time the ones that are mainly on my home
screen are the ones that i most often
use like with most people
but i also have an iphone and that's
where i'll do a lot of stuff that's
just works better on the iphone so i'll
link again this wallpaper for my iphone
below
but again just a bunch of apps that are
good on the iphone that aren't
necessarily as good on android
so things like snapchat uh instagram for
instagram stories
and then there's a bunch of duplicates
just because sometimes i find myself
using the iphone a little more so the
camera
there's google photos at the top for
backing up your photos there is the
actual photos app
and then there's the calendar which is
good for just telling you the date i
don't actually use the calendar app on
the iphone
it's completely blank but the icon shows
the date and that's why i keep it there
there's the
wallet uh the wallet apps on android are
all really
finicky and a little i would say
untrustworthy fun fact if you go to an
apple event
they will actually put a pass in your
wallet app
that they will scan and let you in with
so they just kind of expect you to use
their products
so i have the wallet app then spotify
and soundcloud right next to each other
the app store
settings youtube youtube studio pocket
casts a lot of duplicates as you can see
a lot of competitors next to each other
as well and then i have instagram
and my tic tic app which does sync with
the tick tick app
on my ipad and my android phone and
everything else i love multi-platform
sync
and then in my dock people thought i was
trolling when i put these here but i
have the
the dialer i have the messages app
safari
and the google app and this is going to
give me the same google cards
that are on my android phone uh a little
bit slower not as real time
but i can still trigger google assistant
from here i can still open google lens
and identify things from the camera uh
it still does
all that same stuff then of course on
the second page any iphone user knows
you just have folders of junk that you
don't open that much and since you can't
move them or hide them anywhere to a
drawer my folders of junk are the apple
folder
the utilities folder i have three games
because i don't really game
that much on my phones but i have osmos
asphalt 9 and color road and i have a
google app which has some google apps in
it or google folder so
that's my my junk folder is at the top
pocket dropbox
dark sky again venmo again sky guide in
my opinion sky guide is
the best ar app period
and i'm just going to toss that out
there if you open sky guide
daytime or night and point it at the sky
it will show you in real time where
constellations are
where celestial objects are where the
sun the moon the planets and everything
is
and it overlays it with your actual
environment the trees the buildings the
skyline it's really cool
highly recommended then the activity app
which again if you're
ever concerned about closing rings
there's your history of
rings being closed or sometimes not
closed
but don't pay too much attention to that
and then on the last page i actually use
these more than the middle page so the
series shortcuts app
the snapseed app for photo editing uber
swing u is a golf app
so for those of you who play golf
there's a bunch of apps that do this but
literally it connects to gps and as you
walk around the golf course
it'll tell you exactly how far you are
from the whole from
whatever hazards you're near things like
that it's pretty smart then there's
igtv
yeah i remember that then there's the
hasselblad focus app
in theory it would be the perfect way to
transfer photos from the hasselblad x1d
that i use to my iphone and then edit
them on the iphone
unfortunately it's very very picky and
usually when i want to use it it's a
crowded wi-fi network and it's it's hard
to
switch it over so it could be a lot
better i don't use it much
but i want to use it more the metric
time app for that clock i reviewed a
long time ago then there is
the zedge app which is the one wallpaper
app that i use
on the iphone so
my ipad uh my beloved ipad pro i've
found every excuse to use this
over a macbook pro for example for the
past couple weeks
like i've said in these videos i kind of
gave it a rave review
here's what's on my ipad pro so a lot of
the same stuff that's
been on my iphone is duplicated so i'm
not going to say that stuff again
aside from the fact that yes i have the
calendar up there just because it shows
the date but really i just have three
pages of apps
i don't even have that many trash
folders on here because i use a lot of
the stuff on the ipad
first couple rows i have that apple
folder just to have a bunch of junk in
it
um spotify and soundcloud next to each
other lightroom
tick tick but some of the first true
ipad apps that i have uh are games
golf battle which is it's so stupid it's
literally just a
just a putt-putt game it's mini mini
golf but like with your
hand it's one of those super simple
addicting games
and then earn to die which is a game
i've played on android but it's sort of
like a
a horizontal scroller similar to mario
but you're driving a cart with weapons
on it and zombies are sort of attacking
you that that type of thing and then
osmos hd this is another one of those
games
that just looks amazing on a tablet and
even if it's not the most action-packed
thing
the concept of it i'll leave like i said
links to these below but you play
through it and
it's beautiful there's a great
soundtrack you got headphones on you can
get really immersed in this game so
i'll recommend osmos hd and then just a
bunch of apps that i use
to to get work done on the ipad google
keep google drive
google docs um not even that crazy
professional app so i'm not doing any
video editing on here but i do have
live lightroom cc on here because i can
do photo editing
and then i scroll over and there's some
realtor apps so houzz
for interior design realtor.com i also
have zillow on here i have a weather app
i found this app called medley that kind
of lets you
attempt to make music i'm not very good
at it so i don't
claim to be an expert at that at all but
it's super fun
um netflix i haven't really used netflix
very much over the years i made an
account a long time ago
never really used it but as i've been
going on a lot of flights lately i've
found i've wanted to watch stuff
podcasts don't really last
six whole hours usually uh so there's
some good stuff that i've downloaded
netflix has been a good source for that
i usually try to use my ipad for as much
mobile work as possible i still hate
typing on the ipad here's the thing
about the ipad this is the keyboard
and you can't really quite unless you
have huge hands reach the middle of the
ipad pro keyboard especially if it's
landscape but the ipad pro
is the only ipad where you can't split
the keyboard so i guess on the smaller
ipads you can do this little gesture and
then it splits to the sides and you can
type like this
but on an ipad pro it won't do that so
you end up being this
hunt peck type type of person i
i don't know why so i do most things
like email or things that require a lot
of typing to reply out to stuff or
writing out like video ideas
i do that on my laptop because i have a
real keyboard i can actually type
but i will not be mad if i find myself
stuck with just an ipad pro
and i am i just have to type like
weirdly
with my thumbs in that annoying way i'll
get it done
anyway that's my ipad all right last but
not least
uh the desktop imac pro 2019
fully maxed out this is where the the
editing and and the production and the
magic happens i guess you could say um
but it's also my daily machine
so i'll go through the apps and things
on this so usually it's either in
the launch pad all the stuff in here or
the dock
a lot of people used to do what's on my
dock videos that was good times there
used to be a lot of
a lot of people doing what's on my dock
videos so here's what's in my dock
finder tick tick my to-do list app
that's how i lift then there's final cut
pro
the editing suite of choice uh safari
which is now my default web browser i do
also have chrome but
i do use safari for the most part on the
mac spotify for the desktop
tweetbot for all that twitter goodness
uh the app store of course system
preferences
and the uh control panel for the apollo
twin
uh that i currently use for my audio
setup and i keep my desktop pretty
clean there's usually not a whole lot of
spare extra icons going on
i usually usually have just the web
browser and twitter
up i really really miss the dual screen
setup of the past
back in those days in 2013 and 20
2012 i guess those are the days when i
most often used a dual screen setup and
i'm really excited for the modular mac
this year so i can use whatever monitor
i want
and i can go back to having two but for
now for the most part it's the imac so
it's just one monitor you can see the 80
terabyte rate of attached storage up
here that's the promise pegasus over
here
that shows up because it's a mounted
hard drive that's where i have a whole
bunch of footage
from previous videos and from current
projects
but also down here you can see the
jellyfish as well doesn't show up as a
mounted drive but over there
back behind me that's a 120 terabytes of
hard drives and that's the current
server that's our network attack store
network network attached storage are
they weird if it was attack storage but
it's attached storage but anyway that
shows up as an additional location
it's called jellyfish there's all the
same mkbhd stuff and we have current
video projects
uh and i won't click in there because
there's some top secret stuff but you'll
see that very soon
but that's what we use to have multiple
people working on the same final cut pro
project at the same time really
impressive stuff it's called the
lumaforge jellyfish at least that's what
the hardware is called
and i've loved that so far for like the
past couple weeks but yeah this is this
is the hub this is obviously where
everything has to render
this is where things get uploaded and
published um
and it's been a workhorse so far you can
go back and watch the imac pro review
if you have any other questions about
that but that's basically it
honestly yes just uh just a lot of what
you've seen before in a bunch of other
various places but all
in one video if you have any other
questions i'll hang out in the comments
section below and talk through
whether it's workflow questions or app
questions
or if i forgot a wallpaper or some link
you need me to drop below i'll keep
doing that
but that's basically it thanks for
watching catch you guys in the next one
peace
you